Ask anyone that has been through it, and they’ll
all tell you the same: that moving home is
maybe one of the most stressful things a normal
person can ever experience.
It’s a logistical nightmare right from the
start.
The moment you talk to a realtor about being
interested in selling your current house and
buying another, everything goes downhill from
there.
After that moment, an avalanche of things
comes hurtling towards you – finding a place
you like, making an offer, letting people
look around your house, waiting for them to
make a counteroffer, exchanging contracts
– and that’s before you have even thought
about packing.
And, as Milo had learned, doing all of that
on your own only makes the stress of moving
feel all the more potent.
But he had finally made it.
After a constant back and forth with his realtor,
the time had come for him to pack up all his
worldly possessions and relocate to a brand-new
place to call home.
He had felt it was long overdue for him to
get a change of scenery, and luckily just
the right place had come onto the market to
answer that call.
It was a pretty big house, bigger than Milo’s
previous home, but considerably cheaper – in
fact, he thought it had been significantly
undervalued.
The house had an almost Victorian era feel
to it, all beautifully carved and varnished
woodwork and creaky old floorboards but in
more of an elegant, refined sort of way, rather
than a creepier one.
That’s not to say Milo’s new place wasn’t
without its more…
unsettling elements.
Aside from being big, spacious, and easy to
imagine as being haunted, the creepiest thing
about the house – aside from its frighteningly
low price – was the story of what happened
to the previous owners.
“Obviously you know that, legally, we have
to disclose whether or not anyone died on
this property,” the realtor had explained,
wearing a forced grin as she showed Milo around
the house.
Hearing that sentence, he could feel the hairs
on the back of his neck stand up.
“Someone died here?” he asked in disbelief.
“No, no, of course not, sir!”
the realtor instantly walked back her statement,
less in an effort to ease her client’s nerves,
but more to ensure that she still closed the
deal and earned her commission bonus.
“Then why the hell would you start a sentence
like that?”
Milo asked.
“We just have to give full disclosure, but
I assure you, the previous residents didn’t
die on the grounds of this house.”
She gave that faked smile again; it was pretty
ineffectual at reassuring him.
“So, what happened to the last owner?”
“Well, it’s a bit of a mystery, to be
honest, a local legend, if you like.
But hey, that gives the place more flavor,
having some spooky history, right?
Think of what a conversation starter that
will be!”
The realtor ended her sentence with a forced,
snorting laugh, but reigned it back in when
she realized Milo wasn’t laughing with her.
“As far as I know, there used to be an older
couple living here, the Shaws.
They were apparently very quiet, reclusive,
kept to themselves a lot; I’m sure you know
the type.”
Milo couldn’t help but notice she shot him
a look as she said that part, as if she was
silently passing judgement on the fact that
he was planning on moving in alone.
“But they used to spend a lot of time tending
the garden out front, so their neighbors would
see them pretty frequently, which meant they
were all okay and no one had any bad mishaps
in the house.
You know how old folks can be, such a worry
when they get to that age-”
“Yeah, totally,” Milo interjected, aware
the realtor was stalling.
He repeated: “So, what actually happened
to them?”
“Well, that’s the thing,” she shrugged.
“Nobody knows the full story.
One day the neighbors across the street noticed
they hadn’t seen Mr or Mrs. Shaw for quite
a while.
So, naturally, they came right on over here
to see if they were in.
The last thing they wanted was to assume everything
was hunky-dory here.
I mean, better safe than sorry, right?
But once they got inside, they couldn’t
find either of them, Mr. and Mrs. Shaw were
just… gone.
Vanished without a trace.
Most people on the street thought that they
had sold the place, kept it quiet and moved
away, retired to somewhere nice and exotic.”
“Oh, well, that sounds…
nice, I suppose?”
Milo replied, relieved to hear there hadn’t
been any brutal unsolved murders in the house,
and that it most likely wasn’t haunted.
“That’s just what the neighbors think
anyway,” the realtor continued.
“Of course, they hadn’t sold the house.
They’d just left it.
When my firm came in to repossess this place,
it had all their belongings in it.
Some might even still be laying around here.
Anyway, did you want to have a look at this
contract?”
While, strictly speaking, Milo was the only
human living in his new home, he was never
fully alone.
He had arrived with his two closest friends,
a pair of pets he had adopted while living
in his old house.
One was a hamster by the name of Donut, named
after his round little body and the golden-brown
shade of his fur had reminded Milo of the
glazed, sugary baked treat.
The other was Pixel, a bearded dragon with
a pattern on his scales that resembled some
kind of mosaic art.
The first order of business, Milo had decided,
was before even unpacking, he needed to make
sure his scaly and furry friends each had
a suitable place to stay and that he got them
fed.
Little did he realize there was something
else living in the house with them, something
that was far bigger and was getting much hungrier
than either of his pets would.
Looking around the house, Milo stumbled across
a few boxes that he hadn’t brought with
him.
Like the realtor had said, the Shaws still
had some of their possessions left lying around
the place.
Most of it was useless to Milo, an old man’s
clothes or a set of knitting needles and rolls
of colorful thread.
It was those particular clues that seemed
to imply Mrs. Shaw had a lot of free time
on her hands and maybe took up knitting as
a hobby during retirement.
Of course, the bigger clue was the huge, handmade
blanket that Milo found draped over some of
the remaining boxes in the attic.
He wasn’t exactly well versed in knitwear,
but he could appreciate the craft behind this
soft blanket.
It had clearly had a lot of time and effort
put into making it, painstakingly knitting
each and every individual thread, looping
it around a pair of steel needles, and eventually
– after hours of wearing out shaking, bony
fingers – producing something that actually
looked quite nice.
Even though the idea of sitting and knitting
a blanket might have been one of the most
boring uses of time Milo could imagine, he
still had to admit he was surprised that the
Shaws had left this particular piece of bedding
behind.
It seemed like it would be pretty comfy to
sleep under, and might help keep a person
warm at night now that the colder seasons
were approaching.
What’s more, was that the blanket was clean,
almost like it had been freshly washed.
There was no old person smell on it, no dirt
or discoloration, not a stain, and it hadn’t
even accumulated any dust in its fibers.
In fact, he noticed that there was hardly
any dust at all up in the attic; despite the
house being empty for so long.
He assumed the realtors had hired someone
as a caretaker while they found a buyer for
the place, and they had kept the place clean.
After all, what other conclusion could he
have possibly drawn?
It’s not as if something had eaten all the
dust, that would be absurd…
He’d have a sort through of the Shaws leftovers
later, maybe sell some of it off at a local
yard sale or give it to a thrift store.
But that blanket might come in handy when
it started snowing, so Milo had half a mind
to keep it…
Now, part of what makes moving home such a
stressful life experience isn’t just all
the logistical and administrative parts of
the process.
It’s only made worse by the fact that it
takes forever to move into a new house fully.
That’s the part everyone always forgets
about, the months after a move where you’re
forced to live among towers of cardboard boxes,
all your worldly possessions buried deep within
them, and you can never remember which crate
anything is in when you urgently need it.
So, realizing it would take him much longer
to unpack all of his things, Milo set about
making sure he had everything that Donut and
Pixel would need already to hand.
The latter of his two pets, the bearded dragon,
usually spent most of his days in a spacious
glass tank.
Milo didn’t love the idea of keeping either
of his two best buds so confined, but Pixel
never went very far anyway, content to lay
under a heat lamp almost perfectly still for
most of the day.
Donut, on the other hand, was much more of
a free spirit.
The tiny brown hamster physically could not
stay still, and most days seemed to be filled
with more energy than Milo was.
As a result, he let the little guy roll about
inside a little plastic ball all day long,
until his little hamster feet gave out.
And now, Donut had much more space to zip
around inside his ball, so while he entertained
himself, Milo could focus on what needed fixing,
cleaning, and generally improving around the
house.
It didn’t take him long to realize, however,
that the realtors had pulled a bit of a fast
one on him.
Despite the absolute steal of a price that
Milo had been offered, it quickly became clear
that the unknown fate of the previous residents
wasn’t the only detail about the house that
had been conveniently kept hidden.
The place was in dire need of repair, with
a lot of the old woodwork rapidly rotting
away.
If left unchecked, parts of the house could
collapse and come apart at the seams.
To make matters worse, the boiler was an ancient,
iron monstrosity that was barely able to produce
warm water, which would quickly become an
even bigger problem when the weather started
to get colder.
Then, to top off the trifecta of unforeseen
issues and teething problems with his new
place, Milo couldn’t sleep.
It was to be expected.
After all, the house was old, worn out, and
had definitely seen better days.
There were bound to be a few noises; the odd
creak coming from upstairs when Milo and his
two pets were all downstairs, the tapping
of branches against windows blowing in the
wind outside.
But for some reason, every audible disturbance
that emanated from some hidden corner of the
building only seemed to get a thousand times
louder when the sun went down.
At night time, every squeaky floorboard or
random noise of the house settling was nearly
deafening, enough to pull Milo right out of
what little restless sleep he was getting.
The worst part about it was – though he
couldn’t help it – it made him feel unwelcome,
as if Mr. and Mrs. Shaw were angered that
he had moved in.
In the dark, it was hard not to picture every
sound as one or both of the old couple creeping
through the corridors, coming to reclaim their
home and ‘remove’ Milo from the premises.
One night, the noises started invading what
little sleep Milo did manage to get, spilling
into his dreams and causing them to devolve
into unsettling nightmares.
There was an old photograph in a frame that
had come across in the personal effects lefts
behind by the Shaws, showing the pair of them
staring disapprovingly out of the image at
him.
Now, thanks to the creaking wooden structure
of the house and the sounds it made at night,
Milo was seeing the old couple in every bad
dream he had.
Both their faces were locked in those same
still, frozen expressions of contempt, as
they tried to exorcise him like an interloper
on their property.
That was the final nail in the coffin that
made Milo realize he needed to look at other
options.
Surely, there had to be some way to induce
a deep enough sleep so that the sounds the
house was making weren’t keeping him up
or incepting nightmares anymore.
He called the local doctor, arranging a consultation
for later that day.
As he hung up the phone, something nudged
against his foot.
It was Donut, having rolled through the maze
of cardboard boxes still filling the house.
Milo took one look at the little brown-furred
hamster, then the crates that still littered
the place.
Grabbing the leftover items that the Shaws
had forgotten to take with them before they
vanished, Milo moved those boxes out into
the shed.
He knew he was probably reaching, that it
was hardly likely to make even the slightest
difference to his sleeping, but maybe keeping
their stuff away from him would keep the old
couple out of his head.
The only thing he kept in the house was the
blanket; there was no use letting it go to
waste, especially knowing that the boiler
was on the blink and it would be cold soon.
He rolled it up and left it on his bed, leaving
his more mobile pet in the same room before
heading out to see the doctor.
When Milo got back, a bottle of prescription
sleeping pills in his pocket, he couldn’t
help but notice his room seemed different.
The blanket looked like it had fallen off
the bed and onto the floor, for one.
But more worryingly, Donut’s plastic travel
ball had been split open, laying in pieces
on the ground… with its furry little occupant
nowhere to be seen.
Over the next few hours, Milo searched every
corner of the house, calling out to his hamster,
trying to lure it back with morsels of food.
But Donut didn’t seem to be anywhere, he
wasn’t even underneath the knitted blanket.
Still, there was no sign.
As the worry set in, Milo hurriedly checked
Pixel’s cage to see if he was gone too,
but the lizard was relaxing, as lethargic
as ever, completely unphased by what was going
on.
It certainly seemed that, when it rained,
it really poured in his new house.
Just as he was searching for his missing hamster,
Milo heard a new, horrible sound echo through
the corridors.
This one wasn’t so much a scary noise, even
if it did make him jump, but it was more the
inconvenience that came with it.
Finally, giving out after god knows how many
years it had been installed for, the house’s
boiler burst.
Spending the afternoon into the evening failing
to track down one of his missing pets and
stopping the huge iron cast boiler from flooding
the basement wasn’t exactly what Milo had
in mind for fun activities to do when he got
home.
Going to bed frustrated made it as hard to
sleep as all the nightly cacophony of creaking
floorboards and branches raking against the
windows.
He tapped out two of the pills the doctor
had prescribed him, knocking them back with
a sharp motion of his head and a swig of cold
water, before laying back in bed.
As night had fallen, the temperature had also
plummeted too, and not having a boiler to
heat his room meant that Milo couldn’t stop
himself from shivering in the cold, his breath
forming clouds in front of his face.
He reached for the knitted blanket and threw
it over himself, curling up underneath it
to try and provide an extra layer of warmth
to protect himself from the gnawing cold.
The pills did as they were meant to, helping
Milo to quickly slip into a much deeper sleep
than he had experienced in a while.
Although, it didn’t seem to help with the
nightmares.
Mr. and Mrs. Shaw came back again.
This time they had Milo’s arms and legs
tied up.
With their matching, disapproving faces, the
elderly couple threw something over their
helpless victim and tried to smother him to
death.
For a dream, it felt so intense, so real.
Milo could feel a heavy weight on top of his
body as he slept.
In fact, it felt like it was all around him,
engulfing and crushing the life out of him
from all sides.
But it was the feeling of something wet against
his arm, the sensation of liquid against his
skin, and numbness where his hand should be
were what finally pulled him out of the dream…
and into the nightmare.
Through the dark and his cloudy vision, Milo
could see a wide, gaping maw filled with teeth.
The feeling of being crushed was still surrounding
him, and despite kicking his legs, and trying
to free himself from the confinement, it didn’t
stop squeezing him tighter.
His panic was already making it harder to
catch his breath, but now he could barely
fill his lungs enough to scream for help…
not that anyone was around to hear him.
But it was the sight of his arm that chilled
Milo’s blood.
It wasn’t there anymore.
Part of it just above the elbow was just…
gone.
His hand, fingers, every internal bone, and
muscle had been reduced to a bloody mess,
a slurry of red, melting and coming apart.
It was runny, little more than liquid, resembling
the consistency of sand when it’s underwater
and becomes sludge.
More of his flesh was liquefied, going further
up his arm as the blanket pulled its prey
into its mouth until Milo was no more, not
a trace of him left…
just like the previous owners.
Little did Milo – or the Shaws and Donut
before him – know, but he’d been the victim
of a creature that was part of a rather unique
species.
While they will often vary in their size,
shape, pattern, and other aspects of their
appearance, SCP-799 always seem to be ordinary
items of knitted bedwear, at least at first.
They retain heat like a normal blanket would,
are soft to the touch, and, for the most part,
don’t seem directly harmful.
And usually, they aren’t.
SCP-799s are incapable of much movement, instead
laying still a lot time - not unlike a certain
bearded dragon that just lost its owner.
They also don’t seem to require much in
the way of food, extracting what little nutrition
they do need by drawing in household dust
– a lot of the organic matter in dust is
comprised of dead and discarded human hair
and skin cells, so this makes sense.
This feeding is all done through filtered
mouths in the fibers.
However, this changes if an SCP-799 blanket
is forced to go a long time without food.
While they possess this biological trait themselves,
SCP-799 don’t seem to regard cold-blooded
animals to be sources of food.
In fact, they don’t even seem able to detect
other creatures with cold blood, such as reptiles.
Instead, SCP-799 will metamorphose into a
more predatory form in order to consume any
warm-blooded mammal or human being it encounters,
transforming its feeding orifices and digestive
tract into a singular mouth lined with several
rows of sharp, pointed teeth.
From there, it will wrap up the largest, warm-blooded
animal it can find – whether that be a hamster
or a grown man – and will tear off parts
of its prey, reducing them to little more
than a thin slurry as it digests their body
mass to feed itself.
So, if you move into a new house and come
across an old, knitted blanket…
maybe consider throwing it out… if you want
to live.
Now go and check out “SCP-3032 AND THEN
IT WAS AN ANGRY SPIDER” for more warnings
about everyday objects that can seem harmless
at first, but will quickly turn deadly when
you least expect it.
And after that, if you’re in the market
for a piece of anomalous furniture that’s
still soft and cosy like the blanket, but
nowhere near as dangerous, then “SCP-3832
SURPRISE PILLOW FIGHT” might be just what
you need!